nos preguntan cuáles de las ecuaciones
son siempre equivalentes a la siguiente
ecuación una letra mayúscula representa
una matriz y una letra minúscula
representa un escalar y supongamos que
todas las matrices son cuadradas aquí
tengo esta a mayúscula que es una matriz
cuadrada aquí tengo b mayúscula que eso
de matriz cuadrada y como resultado
tengo d mayúscula que es otra matriz
cuadrada a por b igual a d
y esas son las opciones que tenemos que
analizar nos piden elegir todas las
opciones correctas y como siempre los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolver esto por su cuenta antes de
ver cómo lo solucionamos aquí la primera
opción es b x a iguala de esta no puede
ser ya que la multiplicación de matrices
no es conmutativa aquí el orden sí
importa
si a por ve nos dan d
esta multiplicación al conmutar estas
matrices esto no se puede dar así que
ésta no es correcta
veamos la otra opción es c por a o por b
igual a de porsche se es mayúscula así
que es una matriz cuadrada pero quedamos
que la multiplicación de matrices no es
conmutativa si yo tengo que a por b es
igual a de si esta matriz se está
multiplicando antes ya ve si ésta se
está aquí entonces en el resultado ésta
se debe estar antes de la de antes de
esta matriz pero aquí está se está antes
y en este resultado nos está apareciendo
estas después así que ésta no es
correcta veamos la siguiente era
minúscula es una escalar este escalar
por a por este mismo escalar por b es
igual a este escalar por d
aunque la multiplicación cuando tenemos
escalares si es conmutativa puedo tener
esta r antes o después de la de y va a
ser lo mismo
esta parte no es correcta porque si
sabemos que estos escalares los puedo
mover sin importar el lugar esto es lo
mismo que tener r
estas dos eres las estoy poniendo aquí
juntas y después por a o por b el orden
de las matrices si no lo cambio este se
mantiene esto no es igual a reporte
porque está r por r va a ser r al
cuadrado y esta es una r sencilla no
está al cuadrado esto no es igual por lo
que esto tampoco se cumple veamos la
siguiente opción tengo esta semana
iushko la que es una matriz cuadrada que
multiplica a yahvé y esta matriz
cuadrada que multiplica de bueno de
hecho esto ya lo habíamos analizado acá
si yo tengo esta matriz en este orden
que está se multiplica antes a la y a la
vez tengo esta c que multiplica a la i a
la b
estas dos si a por b es igual a d
entonces voy a tener a esta vez pero
también voy a tener estas antes de la de
esto si es correcto si se cumple porque
no se está cambiando el orden en el que
aparecen estas matrices si tenemos que a
por ver es igual a b y tenemos estas c
antes de estas matrices
esta se también aparecerá antes del
resultado de estas dos matrices así que
esta es correcta veamos la última r es
nuestro escalar este no importa en qué
orden lo ponga por a por b es igual al
mismo escalar r por d eso es correcto
está por b me da esta de esta matriz
cuadrada y si la estoy multiplicando por
un escalar el resultado también va a
estar multiplicado por ese mismo escalar
así que esta es correcta esta opción la
elegimos